This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
Thank you so much for joining us back here for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. I have a bit of a different episode for you all today. I know you all love our deep dives and our really like in-depth searches for the science behind obviously. the experiences of our 20s, but today I want to do something a little bit different and not just focus on one topic for this episode, but talk through a bit of a list. In fact, a list that I have been working on for the past month, basically just outlining the biggest mistakes that people
make in their 20s, from people still in their 20s, all the way up to people who I've spoken to in their 70s and their 80s. I've talked to so many people just kind of sliding in this question into conversation and writing down their answers. What's the biggest mistake that you made during this decade? I even put up a bit of a question box on Instagram. Over 5,000 of you responded or emailed me or DMed me or dropped a comment in an episode and having curated and putting together that whole list,
I want to share some of my very basic findings and, you know, take that list out of my Excel spreadsheet and just share this little personal research project with you guys, the 20 most common mistakes that people say they made in their 20s. You know, in doing this, I kind of had to stop and pause a few times and be like, huh, is this a mistake that I'm maybe currently making? Like what can I learn from this?
What can I learn from these people's experiences? I feel like we're in such a confusing decade of life. And all we really want is someone to give us the answers or for someone to give us, you know, some kind of reassurance that we are doing the right thing and that we're on the right path. Unfortunately for us, obviously, no one can tell you if what you're doing is correct. and they can't tell you what's going to happen next and they can't tell you that you're not going to have regrets, but they can share their own mistakes and their own misturns
and kind of hope that you learn from them. What really inspired me to do this was actually a 2012 publication titled The Five Regrets of the Dying. And these regrets were, I wished I'd had the courage to live a life true to myself. I wish that I hadn't worked so hard. I wish I'd had the courage to express my feelings. I wish I'd stayed in touch of my friends and I'd wish I'd let myself be happier.
These were the regrets of people reflecting on, you know, their whole entire lives. But I wondered if we could make kind of like a decade-specific list to learn from as we go along. So this is that kind of preliminary list. Without further ado, my lovely listeners, there is so much to cover, so much info. And of course, a little bit of psychology. Thank you to every single one of you who shared their regrets, shared their mistakes, whether I talk to you in person, whether you DM'd me. However, you got the information across. It has been truly valuable.
I can't wait to get into it. So let me start by clarifying that this list is by no means like a peer-reviewed study. Like if I submitted this very basic research to like any journal or any publication, you know, I would be. rejected in a heartbeat. You know, this was more of a personal interest project for me that kind of turned into this much bigger thing because I spent obviously a lot of time thinking about my 20s, but what I found does kind of seem to line up with what I thought I was going to find, basically. So I do think that although I wasn't able to get, you know, a sample or like a random sample and I wasn't able to talk to even more people than I would have wanted and I wasn't
able to, you know, apply for an ethics application or do anything like that. This list still has a lot of value. But take it with a grain of salt. If you don't necessarily agree with some of the things on this list, that's totally okay. If you think that we've missed things on this list, also please feel free to leave a comment below because, yes, it's not as comprehensive as I would have liked it to be, but still very, very fascinating. With that in mind, I want to begin by talking about mistake number one. The biggest mistake that people talked about time and time again. I'm going to give you a second to guess what that was.
able to, you, know, apply for an ethics application or do anything like that. This list still has a lot of value. But take it with a grain of salt. If you don't necessarily agree with some of the things on this list, that's totally okay. If you think that we've missed things on this list, also please feel free to leave a comment below because, yes, it's not as comprehensive as I would have liked it to be, but still very, very fascinating. With that in mind, I want to begin by talking about mistake number one. The biggest mistake that people talked about time and time again. I'm going to give you a second to guess what that was.
So by far the biggest mistake that I heard that people made in their 20s was prioritizing a romantic relationship over my friends, over my career, over my personal growth. Essentially, people talking about how they had put romantic attraction at the center of everything that they did and kind of realized later along down the line that it meant that a lot of the other things that mattered to them kind of got pushed to the sidelines. I heard this so often in so many different forms as well. Someone talked about how they had left a job that I loved for a man who dumped them five days later or people who had lost friends because they didn't make time
for them when they were with their ex or being so focused on finding love at 21, 21, 22, 23, that they never spent time growing as a person and learning what they really loved about themselves. These were just a few kind of versions of this same mistake that I heard. And you know what? I relate to this very, very deeply. I remember being 19, 20, just like desperately wanting to be chosen by someone, you know, at a club, at a party, on a dating app. it became such an obsession that what I thought was love became my only priority and everything else in my life kind of suffered. I just wish I could tell that version of myself, you know, from only like five, seven years ago just to slow down a little bit. Like just to have some fun.
Treat dating like an experiment. Treat dating like you're studying humankind and figuring out what you like and what you don't and what works for you and what kind of person elevates your life. life rather than just kind of to use this analogy jumping in the first cab off the rank and hoping that it's the right one and kind of later on finding that it probably wasn't. You guys know that I did a bit of a dating detox in my early 20s where I didn't date, I didn't have dating apps, I didn't think really about men for almost half a year and it was during that time that I can firmly say my career took off. I made more friends and incredible friends more than I really think I'd ever had.
I really fell in love with myself. And now that I am in a relationship and we live together, we have a dog together, it feels like the right thing. And it feels like actually that relationship is not my whole world, when I used to make relationships my whole world. How I think about it is like, here's this separate universe for me that I can step into and enjoy alongside and in parallel to this life that I've built myself. Like, my whole world is a life that is more than just love.
So if you will want to avoid what seems like a very big regret or mistake for many people, treat love as something that is fantastic if it finds you. But not everything, especially during this decade, should revolve around it. I heard this analogy the other day that I love. If you knew you would meet the love of your life in six months, how would you live those next six months to the fullest as a single person? And yes, you might not actually meet them in six months, but aim to live like every single day, every single week in that same mindset and with that same perspective for as long as you can.
That's mistake number one. Similar to that mistake, another one that was very closely related and came in second was people who talked about staying in a relationship when they knew it wasn't right for them. That was the second biggest mistake that I heard. This isn't so much about centering the pursuit of love in your life. It's more so about people who found a love that they thought worked and held on to it perhaps for longer than they should have. A lot of these people talked about either A, knowing very early on that this person wasn't for them and not acting sooner, or B, you know, not even knowing. that and not even knowing how to act at all, not knowing and having doubts whether, like
doubting your doubts, doubting whether your perception of this person was correct for so long that by the time you knew that they weren't, you really didn't know even how to change things. You were living together, you had pets together, maybe you were even married, you had kids together and just not knowing how to pull out of that relationship. when things finally end, quite a number of people spoke about how it felt like they'd kind of wasted their youth, they have to start all over again, and how they, you know, maybe didn't completely regret the relationship, but definitely kind of wanted some of those years back. You do have to give yourself a lot of grace in these situations, though, because whether someone
is right for you or not is actually a really tricky question to answer. Like, how do you really not? how can you really trust that that instinct isn't just relationship anxiety or relationship OCD or just general anxiety? Personally, I think it's really, really hard because relationships are tricky sometimes. Like every single relationship is going to have its trials and knowing whether that's a deal breaker or just something that you have to get through is kind of difficult to understand when maybe this is like your first relationship or, you know, you haven't had the most healthy example.
of what healthy love looks like, you kind of just assume that this must be it. Also, just to add to this, if you're someone who has always had a specific timeline for your life kind of imposed upon you by society, by parents, by culture, if you're someone who struggles being alone, it can be a lot easier to settle for good enough in order to fill that void or fill that expectation and only realize like a lot later down the line that you've made a mistake. Okay, we're going to move on from the romance and love mistakes and talk finances. A big number of the mistakes that people relayed that they made in their 20s related to money. Here are the three that came up the most, in no certain order, just the three that were very, very common. The first one was not saving.
The second one was not investing sooner. And the third mistake. mistake was getting a credit card. The savings one was huge. One quote from a listener that really stood out was this. Yes, money does come and go, but experiences last forever and that matters, but you also need to support yourself to have those experiences. The stress I put myself through to go to festivals, to have a Euro summer when I couldn't afford it, to go out for dinner, to buy new clothes was not worth it. I wish I knew what I knew now and had saved more. We can learn a lot from that. When it comes to saving and investing, I beg of you, please just choose like one day this month to sit down and freshen up on your financial literacy.
You don't have to have a lot of money to know how your money works and what it can do for you. You don't have to have a lot of money before you start. Like, you don't actually have to invest. You don't actually have to do anything with that information. It's just important that you know this stuff early in your 20s. when it's easier to learn and to kind of decide what you want financially for your future. I'll be honest, I put this off for so long. And it was only a couple of months ago that I did really have to say to myself, like,
enough. I have to get my money together. I have to learn how investing works, what budget is best, which bank to be with, how to use different accounts and point systems and high interest accounts and whatnot. And I just dedicated like two days across like a two month period, to just learning and listening to podcasts and reading articles and following people who talked about this. And it did make me feel so much more secure and knowledgeable. It definitely eased a lot of anxiety that I had around my future with my money. And I'm going to express that same sentiment
that the woman who DM'd me said, I definitely wish that when I was 23 or even younger, I knew what I knew now because it definitely could have saved me a lot of money and saved me a lot of stress and probably impacted my future in a way that I'm probably not ready to even think about, like having that extra money in like my savings or in my super account, my retirement fund. I try not to think about the opportunities that I missed out on not doing that earlier. There are also so many different ways to budget. Like some people use the 50, 30, 20 method. So 50% for needs, 30% for once, 20% for savings.
others like the 70-20-10 method. Some people give themselves like a maximum amount each month that they can spend and everything else goes into savings and they don't touch that. Whatever it is, find something that works and start even when it feels intimidating. As for that third financial mistake, I regret getting a credit card. Take that advice seriously. Credit cards are great for building a credit score and finding ways to to get money back and perks and travel points,
but my rule has always been and it will continue to be. If I don't need it and I can't afford it, I don't need it. Only buy things with a credit card that you can hopefully pay off immediately. Obviously there are some big purchases like buying a house or a car where it's a bit different, but in terms of just like every day wants like clothes, like travel, like homewares, like whatever it is, if you don't need it and you can't afford it, you don't need it. I actually found a study that concluded around two-thirds of people in their 20s have credit card debt. And another publication was saying that the average amount of that debt is
around $6,000, $6,000. That's scary stuff. And if you don't know what you're doing to get that debt down, that can follow you. If you don't know how to correctly use a credit card as a tool rather than as a lifeline, it can get you into a lot of danger. So reflect on those mistakes, do what you wish with that knowledge. Moving on, there was another group of mistakes that I heard time and time again. And they have to do with how we let others' thoughts, opinions and actions affect us. Mistake number six was putting people's needs above my own. Another one high up on that list, not learning to say no.
And finally, worrying too much about what people thought of me. all kind of in the same vein, I would say. Let me say this. How you think about yourself, how you treat yourself, what you learn to tolerate and not tolerate when it comes to other people's behavior, that has a much bigger impact than we think. And it definitely snowballs. Like it may be small in the moment to just say yes
and to just kind of be passive in the face of someone else's assertions. We may not even notice it, but it can shape our whole life if we end up being steered in a direction that we didn't want to go to make other people happy. Maybe that's like choosing a certain career. Maybe that is earlier like choosing a certain partner that you think will meet your parents' expectations. Maybe it's just letting friends treat you badly. That does something to your soul and it does something to your sense of self that can be harder
to repair the older we get. And I also think the older we get, the more we realize that life is really, really fine. night and you only really get one shot and you owe it to yourself to be fierce and to really stand up for yourself. You know, at the end of the day when you're looking back, you want to feel like you were in control and you didn't continuously sacrifice your own happiness for someone else's comfort, especially, especially when they don't even end up appreciating it. Let me say, a lot of the time these reactions are instinctual. So I don't want you to feel like there's shame around having done this or this being something you want to unlearn.
A lot of the time, these actions aren't just instinctual. They were also conditioned over many years since we were children to be, you know, good and to be agreeable and to just let others have their way or have their say. It is your job to deliberately unlearn these mechanisms. It is your job at some stage in your life to unlearn your tend to unlearn your tend to unlearn your tendency to shrink or to make yourself small. And it will be uncomfortable at first. You know, it is uncomfortable to upset people. It is uncomfortable to hear mean things or to disappoint people or to say no. Of course it's uncomfortable because you're not used to doing it. But on the other side of that
discomfort is a life that it's just, you know, the only word I have for it is lighter. There's like no better word for it. It's lighter. You just feel like you can move through like the waves of life with a lot more ease. You know, we've talked about financial investments. Learning that your opinion and your needs should come first, this is the kind of personal and emotional investment that pays dividends and will bring you so much more happiness. I have a whole episode on this if you want to learn more about how to do that titled How to Care Less About What People Think About You. It really breaks down an exact strategy that you can go about doing this. So go there after this if you need more tips. As we move down this list, almost halfway through now, this next
one sticks out to me particularly because it's probably one of my mistakes and probably one of my biggest regrets from this decade so far. Not keeping up with old friends. Now, it's true. You cannot keep every single friend that you have ever made, but there have certainly been times when I've realized, you know, far too late that I really should have meant. message that person back. I really should have answered their calls. I really should have kept in touch. And at some stage, you kind of, I guess, like months pass and you kind of wake up and you're like, wait, whatever happened to that person? And wow, they were a really good friend. I wish that I had appreciated them more. You know, you miss them, but you're at this weird point where you don't
really know how to invite them or invite yourself, I guess, back into their life. Friends as well kind of hold pieces of who we are and therefore as well who we used to be. So losing touch with them does sometimes feel like losing part of ourselves and that can hit especially hard during periods of loneliness or transition that obviously very synonymous with this decade. I remember when I first moved to Sydney, I've spoken about this before, I lost a lot of friends and I didn't really like appreciate how hard that was until later on. And now I'm at a stage where I really want to reflect back on that time when they were present. And I don't, you know, they're not there to do that with me. And they're not there for me to learn from or to talk to. And it's kind of lonely and it's
kind of sad. We have so much research out there. I couldn't even begin to cite it that tells you that long-term social bonds are just as crucial for your emotional health and your physical health as so many other lifestyle decisions that we make. So when we let those bonds fade, you know, it's not just about missing a friend. It's about really missing a grounding presence in our life and kind of missing out on all these like health benefits and like the secret to longevity. The secret to longevity is having people around you who love you and care about you. Please don't forget about that in the pursuit of your career or in your pursuit of love or in the current busyness of the life and the decade that you are in right now. Okay, we are over halfway through this list now.
We're going to touch on one more mistake that made the list, the early parts of the list, before taking a break. And it's different from everything we've kind of talked to. It's different from friendship. It's different from money. It has to do with our health. The biggest health mistake on the list was smoking. I wish I'd never smoked my first cigarette.
I wish I hadn't started vaping. I wish nicotine had never entered my life. That was repeated time and time again. one person wrote in who was in their 50s. And the way she found the podcast was that she'd listened to a few episodes with her daughter. And she wrote into me when I was asking people for their biggest mistakes, saying how she started smoking at 20 to impress a guy. She got addicted.
And as everyone else around her slowly quit when they left for college, when they had kids, when they got married, she didn't. And I have permission from her to share this, but she basically said, I've never been able to run more than a kilometer. my kids have asked me multiple times, so many times to quit, and I know in my heart one day I'll get an unthinkable call from the doctor and it will be cancer. If only I was 20 again and I could reverse it all and reverse this decision. That kind of left me a little bit speechless, you know, hearing from someone,
this big reflection on their life and almost this call, this like, it almost felt like she was like begging people in their 20s to just take their, health more seriously as someone who could see what happens when you don't. And we can learn so much from stories like that. And yes, smoking is highly addictive. It's calming. You know, it looks cool. It's cultural. It's social. It's also a habit that does damage that time cannot repair. And when you're young and healthy, you have the benefit of not having to think about that. But your oldest self is begging current you to think about them, to think about the future, to think about how you're going to feel when you really start to see the very dangerous side effects of this habit.
Nowadays as well, you know, it's not just smoking. I also heard a lot about vaping. You know, for the first time in decades, I was looking at this research the other day. The use of nicotine has like shot way up. Like there was this very steady trajectory over the years of like nicotine intake going down, going down with education, with people learning the consequences. But when vaping was introduced, you know, it's like this new thing. And with any new thing, there's not long-term research into the health consequences. And it was definitely marketed as like a healthy alternative.
And like something that wasn't as bad for you as smoking. This is what I think about that. When people say like, oh, but smoking, but vaping is so much healthier than smoking, I think like, that's like saying getting stabbed as a healthier alternative to being shot with a gun. Like, it might be true, but a knife still isn't going to feel great and it's still going to hurt and it's still not particularly good for you. So I would really encourage people who do vape and want to stop just to read up on the health consequences. We now are seeing studies come out.
There was a 2023 study titled, E-Cigarette Harm's Aggregate Evidence that Shows Damage to Biological Systems. if you want to get nerdy and read that study. It's one of the first long-term ones that shows what is really happening to your lungs and your body when you vape. Wow, I feel like I'm like a health advertisement right now. But I'm going to take a short break now that I've kind of drilled into you a number of mistakes.
I'm going to let you process some of them, get a cup of tea, get a glass of water. When we return, we're going to talk about mistakes related to family, taking risks, and why seemingly more people are seeing college as a mistake these days. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more.
look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
在我的新播客节目《艰难成长》（Learn the Hardway）中，我们将深入探讨治愈、成长、父亲角色、压力和目标等真实话题。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难成长》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detainty.
发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她谎言中的惊人矛盾。这开启了长达数年的诉讼之战以证明真相。你曾两次伪造这个特定的测试给某人，对吗？我伪造过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探
to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款是如何被使用的。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura O'Brien. Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So our careers are probably, I'm going to say this, our biggest source of stress and anguish in our 20s.
这里是“爱之陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要面对后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·奥布莱恩。欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“爱之陷阱”播客。所以我们的职业生涯，我要这么说，很可能是我们20多岁时最大压力和痛苦的来源。
You know, big questions to do with our careers. What's our dream job? Will I ever find something I care about? Like, how can I create the lifestyle that I want? Will I ever have a sense of purpose? Big questions, my friends. A lot of that starts with, should I go to college? Should I get an education?
你知道，与我们职业相关的大问题。什么是我们的梦想工作？我能找到我真正在乎的事情吗？比如，我该如何创造我想要的生活方式？我能找到人生目标吗？朋友们，这些都是大问题。其中很大一部分始于：我该上大学吗？我应该接受教育吗？
Or should I get my foot in the door career-wise and get experience and kind of not get a degree right now, but go back? The interesting thing that I found is that there was almost a 50-50 split, just in the people that damned me or reached out to me, between the people who said college was a mistake and it was a waste of money. and people who said, I regret not going to college and not prioritizing my education. It's very interesting, and I think, obviously, you're probably listening to this being like, well, that doesn't help me. But let's have a little bit of a discussion around why people said college wasn't worth it and the people who said that they wish they had done it. I think these days, going to university just kind of seems like the necessary next step for a lot of us. But having a degree, we all know this. It doesn't necessarily guarantee you a job.
还是应该在职业上迈出第一步，积累经验，暂时不拿学位，以后再去读？我发现有趣的是，私信我或联系我的人当中，几乎有百分之五十对百分之五十的平分：一部分人说上大学是个错误，是在浪费钱；而另一部分人则说，我很后悔当初没有上大学，没有把教育放在首位。这非常有趣，而且我想，你听了肯定会觉得：嗯，这对我没什么帮助。但让我们来讨论一下，为什么有人觉得大学不值得上，而另一些人则说他们希望当初去读了。我认为现在去上大学对我们很多人来说似乎成了必要的一步。但拥有一个学位，我们都知道，并不一定能保证你找到工作。
Even having a master's. Even having a PhD, you know, it's incredibly costly. It's a huge time investment. It doesn't necessarily guarantee that you're going to be further ahead or have more opportunities. That is why I think a lot of people are starting to question its kind of necessity. Personally, I think education is always valuable. It is an asset, even if it's an asset that more and more people have. It gives you more than just skills.
甚至拥有硕士学位，甚至拥有博士学位，你知道，这代价极其高昂，是一笔巨大的时间投资。它并不一定能保证你会走得更远或拥有更多机会。这就是为什么我认为很多人开始质疑它的必要性。就我个人而言，我认为教育永远是有价值的。它是一项资产，即使这项资产被越来越多的人拥有。它带给你的不仅仅是技能。
Just being in that environment, you know, it gives you a network. It gives you mentors. It exposes you to ambitious people and just people who will become your friends and will help you get ahead. But if you don't have a specific thing that you want to do and you're just going to college or university to tick it off the list and you're not being present in your classes, you're not paying attention, you're not really getting involved in that experience. You feel like you have no motivation at all.
仅仅身处那种环境中，你知道，它能为你提供人脉，为你提供导师。它让你接触到有雄心的人，以及那些会成为你的朋友并帮助你取得成功的人。但如果你没有一件具体想做的事，去上大学或读研只是为了打勾完成任务，并且你在课堂上不投入、不专心、没有真正参与到那种体验中，觉得完全没有动力，
it might actually not be worth it. And that's what some people are saying to me. Instead, like going into the workplace, taking a gap here, those might be more valuable in giving you maturity and experience and more of a direction. And they should be presented as things that are valuable to do at any stage, but also straight out of high school. It should be just as normalized to go and get an apprenticeship or to go on work
那它其实可能并不值得。这也是有些人对我说的话。相反，比如进入职场、gap year（间隔年），这些对于带给你成熟度、经验和更多的方向感可能更有价值。它们应该被视为在任何阶段都很有价值的事情，高中毕业后也是如此。去当学徒或去工作
or to go and, you know, travel abroad after high school. school as it is to just like jump straight into university. Otherwise, and I've spoken to people who feel this way, you know, you wake up at 21, 22, 23, you've just graduated university and you realize that you have spent 19 to 20 years being in school. Like this was a realization I had when I graduated from uni. I was like, oh my God, this is the first time in my life that I'm going to spend more than three months not studying or not like being in a classroom. And if you haven't done some soul searching during that period, like, and if education is all you've ever known, like, you're going to feel quite lost and you're going to feel a bit scared. So it is something to consider. Is this
或者高中毕业后去国外旅游，应该和直接跳进大学一样被正常对待。否则——我也和持这种观点的人聊过——你知道，你在21岁、22岁、23岁醒来，刚刚大学毕业，然后你意识到你已经花了19到20年时间在学校里。就像我从大学毕业时也有这种顿悟一样。我当时想：天哪，这是我人生中第一次有连续三个多月不用学习，也不用待在教室里。如果你在那段时间里没有进行过灵魂深处的探索，而且教育又是你唯一熟悉的一切，你就会感到非常迷茫，甚至有点害怕。所以这确实值得考虑。这
necessarily the best thing for me to do right now? I can't answer for you, but just take that wisdom and do what you want with it. I've also been loving this. I do. recently of people who take their retirement throughout their life rather than just at the end of their life. You know, normalizing, not needing to save up all your experiences for your 60s, but having them throughout your career and throughout your professional life, taking little mini gap years, taking like mini sabbaticals. And you know, anything can happen. I always remember the story I was told of this couple who were in their 60s and they were nearing retirement, the wife had retired, the husband hadn't, and he kept saying, oh, let me just one more year, we could just get a little
绝对是我现在必须做的最好的事吗？我无法替你回答，但请吸收这些智慧，并随心所欲地利用它们。我也一直很喜欢这种做法。我最近看到一些人，他们选择在整个人生中分段享受退休生活，而不是只在生命的尽头才退休。你知道，让这种观念正常化：不需要把所有的体验都存到60多岁再去享受，而是在你的职业生涯和专业生活中随时去体验，去度过短暂的迷你间隔年，进行短暂的迷你休假。而且你知道，任何事情都可能发生。我总是记得别人给我讲过的一个故事：有一对60多岁夫妇，他们临近退休，妻子已经退休了，丈夫还没有，他一直说，哦，让我再干一年吧，我们就能多赚一点点钱，
bit extra money, one more year, one more year, and then we can go and finally have all the money that we want for this big, amazing trip. And she had a heart attack and she died before they could do that. You know, he was six months out from like finally saying like I'm done and she'd been retired for six years and she never got to do those things. And that can happen. Like life is very unpredictable. So do what you want to do whilst you have the youth and whilst you have the time and whilst you have the desire to do it. So this kind of relates to three other common mistakes that I heard, which were people regretting not having a gap here, people making the mistake of jumping right into work and feeling to enmeshed with their professional identity so that it made it very hard for
再干一年，再干一年，然后我们就能去享受我们想要的所有资金，开启这次盛大美妙的旅行了。结果她突发心脏病，在他们成行之前去世了。你知道，他离说“我终于退休了”只有六个月的时间，而她已经退休六年了，却再也没有机会去做那些事。这种情况是会发生的。生活非常不可预测趁你还年轻、有时间、有渴望的时候，去做你想做的事吧。所以这有点类似于我听到的其他三个常见错误：人们后悔没有过间隔年，人们犯了直接投入工作、与职业身份过度捆绑的错误，以至于很难
them to quit a job or quit a career or take a step back. And number three, people feeling like they haven't traveled and they haven't explored. And now they're in a period where they're settling down and they regret that. We live in a current state of the world in a current society that is very much dictated by what your resume looks like, what you've achieved, your job title, your dedication to the hustle, what you can present as successful to others. And that can be very hard to step away from. It can be very hard to step away from because often there's this implicit idea that if you take a break or you do something for your personal development, you're going to miss out on a critical formative period for your professional development. And by the time you come
辞掉工作、放弃职业或者退一步。第三点，人们觉得自己没有去旅行，没有去探索。现在他们正处于安定下来的阶段，对此感到后悔。我们生活在当今的世界和当代社会中，它很大程度上由你的简历长什么样、你取得了什么成就、你的职位头衔、你对内卷的奉献、你能向他人展现出多大的成功来决定。要从中抽身出来可能会非常困难。这很难抽身，因为通常存在一种潜在的观点：如果你休息一下，或者为个人发展做点什么，你就会错过职业发展的一个关键形成期。等你
back, like you've missed the boat, you're never going to get that time back. You are falling so far behind you and never be able to catch up. It's a common myth. Here's two things that I'll say to that. building your career is not linear. People can get somewhere in five years and it's going to take someone else 30 years to get to that same place. It's what happened during those years in terms of your life experience that matters more and will matter more at the end of the day. Secondly, if we think back to that list from people on their deathbeds,
回来时，就像错过了末班车，你再也找不回那些时间了。你已经落后太远，再也追不上了。这是一个常见的神话。对此我想说两点：建立职业生涯并不是线性的。有人可能在五年内达到某个位置，而另一个人可能需要三十年才能到达同一个地方。在那些年里，对你的人生体验而言，真正重要的是什么，到了最后一天，这才是更重要的。其次，如果我们回想一下临终之人的遗愿清单，
people who have their whole life to kind of survey and examine the number two regret they say, not just people in their 20s, people like in their 80s and 90s, I wish I hadn't worked so hard. These are people who have every reason to be honest, who have years more of life lessons than we do, who would probably give anything to have a second shot to live a life with the wisdom they have now.
那些有一生时间去审视和检验的人，他们说出的第二大遗憾——不仅是20多岁的人，还有80多岁、90多岁的人——是“我希望我当初没有那么拼命工作”。这些人完全有理由说真话，他们的人生阅历比我们多得多，他们很愿意付出任何代价来获得第二次机会，用现在的智慧去过一种生活。
And they have gifted us that wisdom. We want wealth, we want success, and the reason many of us want that is so at the end of the day we can travel, we can sit and enjoy life, we can have nice things. you can also have them now. This is actually the best time to travel. It's the best time to explore. You might not have the big budget that you want,
他们把这份智慧赠予了我们。我们渴望财富，我们渴望成功，我们许多人渴望这些的原因是，在最后的那一天我们可以去旅行，我们可以坐下来享受生活，我们可以拥有美好的事物。但你现在也可以拥有它们。这其实是旅行的最佳时期。这也是探索的最佳时期。你可能没有你想要的巨额预算，
but you do have your youth, and you do have the opportunities to make really great stories and develop experiences and skills that will impact you for longer. You are the youngest you will ever be, the healthiest, most likely. You have the stamina, you don't have obligations. Older people may have the money, but they don't have all that you have now.
但你拥有青春，你拥有创造极佳故事的机会，并能够培养出对你产生长期影响的经历和技能。现在的你将是你一生中最年轻的时候，也是最健康的。你拥有充沛的精力，没有过多的家庭负担。老年人可能有钱，但他们没有你现在所拥有的一切。
Another mistake people felt that they made, was not taking risks, not chasing their dream, and in a similar vein, wasting time thinking rather than doing. This really reminds me of another story that I was told by someone recently about her mother and how her mother trained to be an accountant and she spent all these years working her way up, being an accountant. And then like 30 years into the career, she was like, had a complete mental breakdown and was just like, I've wasted so much of my time. I feel so unhappy. She read The Artist's Way, if you know that book, Dochi references a lot.
人们觉得他们犯下的另一个错误是：没有去冒险，没有去追逐梦想。与之类似的是，把时间浪费在思考上而不是行动上。这真的让我想起最近有人给我讲的一个关于她母亲的故事。她母亲接受过会计培训，花了多年时间一步步晋升为一名会计。然后，在职业生涯的大约30年后，她精神彻底崩溃了，觉得“我浪费了太多时间。我感到太不快乐了”。她读了《艺术家之路》（如果你知道这本书的话，多奇经常提到它），
It's incredible. She read The Artist's Way and she dropped everything and became an artist. And now she's an incredibly successful artist. And the real moral of the story is something that she said to my friend, which now feels permanently, kind of see it into my brain. The safe option is the safe option for a reason, because it will always be there. Because you can always go back to it. People can't always say the same about their dreams.
这本书太不可思议了。她读了《艺术家之路》，然后放弃了一切，成为了一名艺术家。现在她是一位极其成功的艺术家。这个故事真正的寓意是她对我的朋友说过的一句话，现在这句话已经永远深深地烙印在我的大脑里：“稳妥的选择之所以是稳妥的选择，是因为它永远都在那里。因为你随时可以回到它身边。”但人们却不能对自己的梦想做出同样的保证。
it's something I've definitely seen. Big dreams that you have for your life, big dreams that are really calling out to you, they don't always wait around. And it becomes harder and harder to do them the older you get. If you want some research to back this up, because obviously I can't just go a whole episode without citing at least one paper,
这是我绝对亲眼所见的事情。你为生活许下的宏大梦想，那些真正召唤你的伟大梦想，它们并不总是会在原地等待。而且随着年龄的增长，去实现它们的难度会越来越大。如果你需要一些研究来支撑这一点，因为显然我不可能录制一整期节目却连一篇论文都不引用，
you've got to hear about this study that they did at Cornell. So this team of researchers, they recruited hundreds of participants to share their regrets, kind of like what I'm doing now, but professionally. And they then divided all of these regrets and their answers into two different categories. Those involving the ideal self, i.e. what you dreamed you'd be or what you felt and in a drive to become. And regrets involving the ought to self, i.e. those that dealt with not meeting expectations or the ideals of others. Which type of regret do you think was most common?
你必须听听他们在康奈尔大学做的这项研究。这组研究人员招募了数百名参与者来分享他们的遗憾，有点像我现在做的这样，但这是专业性质的。然后，他们将所有这些遗憾及其回答分成了两个不同的类别。那些涉及理想自我的，也就是你梦想成为的人，或者你在追求中感受到的；以及涉及应当自我的遗憾，也就是那些未能达到他人期望或理想的遗憾。你认为哪种遗憾最常见？
ideal self-regrets won by a landslide. Participants had more regrets around their ideal self and around things that they wish they'd done to make their dreams come true over regrets around things that they wish they'd done to impress others or regrets over things they wish they'd done because they ought to have done them. So the math is on your side. Like if you want less regret, aim higher for yourself. do more to become your ideal self.
理想自我的遗憾以压倒性优势获胜。参与者对理想自我、以及那些他们希望为了实现梦想而做的事情，有着更多的遗憾，相比之下，那些为了给别人留下深刻印象而做的事，或者他们认为自己应该做的事，遗憾则要少得多。所以概率站在你这边。如果你想减少遗憾，就为自己树立更高的目标，多做能成为理想自我的人。
Take further risks and it kind of seems like logically, scientifically, I could even say, like you will die a happier person with a happier life. Okay, we have three final mistakes in our list and they're all very different and they were all kind of hard to put into any of these other categories. They were standalone regrets. The first mistake was not getting help for my mental health soon.
承担更多风险，从逻辑上、科学上来说，我甚至可以说，你会带着更快乐的心情、过着更幸福的生活离世。好了，我们的清单上还有最后三个错误，它们都非常不同，而且很难归入前面提到的任何其他类别。它们是独立的遗憾。第一个错误是没有尽早为我的心理健康寻求帮助。
I heard this quite a bit and oh my gosh, if I personally could only go back in time and tell myself this, I think I would have saved myself a lot of suffering. Your mental health is your most precious asset. People say it's physical health. It's your mental health by far because it comes from the mind and the mind really does control a whole lot. It controls everything. If your mind is suffering, everything else will suffer. It controls who you are, what you think about yourself, your beliefs, your dreams, your interests, your relationships, everything. So please tend to this part of you like it is the precious asset that it is, especially when
我经常听到这种说法，天哪，如果我个人能时光倒流并告诉自己这一点，我想我会省去很多痛苦。你的心理健康是你最宝贵的资产。人们说是身体健康。远不止如此，是你的心理健康，因为它源于大脑，而大脑确实掌控着一切。它掌控着一切。如果你的大脑在痛苦，其他一切都会痛苦。它掌控着你是谁、你如何看待自己、你的信仰、你的梦想、你的兴趣、你的人际关系，一切。所以请像对待你那宝贵的资产一样关爱你的这部分，尤其是当你
you're young, because you can learn so many skills that will carry you through and give you a healthier life mentally if you learn them earlier. Know that as well, no matter how stuck you feel, how hard it is right now, people trained for years to be able to help you through this. And they will be able to help you through this. They have thousands of tools to help you feel better and more like yourself. One of them will work. So if you have been putting it off, if you've been waiting for the right time,
年轻的时候，因为你可以学到很多技能，这些技能会伴随你一生，如果你早点学到它们，会让你拥有更健康的心理。还要明白，无论你感觉多么无助，现在有多么艰难，都有人经过多年培训能够帮助你度过难关。他们能够帮你度过难关。他们有成千上万种工具可以帮你感觉更好、更像你自己。其中总有一种会管用。所以如果你一直拖延，如果你一直在等待合适的时机，
thinking that you can get through it on your own, basically, no, you don't have to. The second kind of standalone regret that I heard a lot or mistake was not asking my parents' important questions and not spending time with them. When we're in our 20s, we go through a very natural period of separation from our family. families. Everyone does. It's an important stage in our development. It's known in developmental psychology as individuation. You have to be able to form your own independent identity away from the safety and the structure of the family. But at some stage, you do emerge from this period and you kind of come back to your parents and come back to your family members and see them differently. And I think the way you see them now is as not equals, but as the adults that they are
以为你可以靠自己挺过去，其实，不，你不需要。我听得最多的第二种独立遗憾或错误是没有问父母重要的问题，也没有花时间陪伴他们。当我们二十多岁时，我们会经历一个非常自然的与家庭分离的时期。每个人都会经历。这是我们成长中的一个重要阶段。在发展心理学中被称为“个体化”。你必须能够脱离家庭的安全感和结构，形成自己独立的身份。但在某个阶段，你确实会从这个时期走出来，重新回到父母身边，回到家庭成员身边，并以不同的方式看待他们。我想你现在看待他们不再是以平等的身份，而是以他们作为成年人的身份
with complex lives the same way that you have a complex internal life. And you want to know more about them. You want to know more about who they were before they were a parent, who they were before they were a partner, who they were as a child, all these things. Don't miss that opportunity and don't miss that window. I've been doing this with my own grandparents a lot recently. I feel very lucky that, you know,
他们有着复杂的生活，就像你拥有复杂的内心生活一样。你想更多地了解他们。你想了解他们在成为父母之前是谁、在成为伴侣之前是谁、在作为孩子时是谁，所有这些。不要错过这个机会，也不要错过这个窗口。最近我一直在和我的祖父母这样做。我觉得自己很幸运，你知道的，
I still have three very healthy and alive grandparents who have incredible stories. And every time I see them, I really make an effort to just say, you know, what was like the snacks that you liked when you were my age? Or what was your best friend's name? Or what did you learn from your first job? Just like small questions because they are literally like a textbook on how to live a good life. And they're a textbook that I have access to that is like literally right there and open and ready for me to learn from.
我仍然有三位非常健康的健在的祖父母，他们有难以置信的故事。每次见到他们，我都真的努力去问他们，你知道的，你当我这个年纪时喜欢吃什么零食？或者你最好朋友的名字是什么？或者你从第一份工作中学到了什么？只是一些小问题，因为他们简直就像一本关于如何过上好生活的教科书。这是一本我触手可及的教科书，就在那里，翻开着，随时准备让我去学习。
A lot of people spoke about having lost their parents or, you know, things happening that has meant that they can't really stay in touch with them. and the mistake that really feels like and how that weighs heavy. The final mistake on this list, and I feel like it is the best place to end, not spending more time alone getting to know myself. An interesting thing about this one was that this was one that I heard a lot more from older people, a lot more from people over the age of 40.
很多人谈到失去了父母，或者你知道的，发生了一些事情意味着他们无法真正与父母保持联系，这种遗憾的感觉是怎样的，以及它是多么沉重。这份清单上的最后一个错误，我觉得这是最完美的结束方式，那就是没有花更多时间独自相处来了解自己。关于这一点，有趣的是，我从年龄较大的人那里、从40岁以上的人那里听到这个说法的频率要高得多。
it feels like an important one to finish with. I say this in my book, I say this on my podcast so many times that if you're a frequent listener, you're probably going to be annoyed that I'm saying it again. And I apologize in advance, but there is only one relationship that you will have your entire life. There is one person. You will spend more time with than anyone else in existence. And that's you. You are always there.
感觉这是一个很重要的结束话题。我在我的书里说过，在我的播客里也说过好多次，如果你是常听的听众，你可能会厌烦我再次提起。我提前道歉，但你一生中只会拥有一段这样的关系。只有一个人。你与他在一起的时间将超过世上任何人。那就是你自己。你永远都在那里。
You will always be with you. There's a quote I love from Carl Jung, which is that the privilege of a lifetime is to know who you truly are. And that starts with really being able to spend time alone to put a mirror up to your soul and your sense of self and examine it. Explore the parts of you that feel uncomfortable. Try new things. Be present with your thoughts. Go on dates with yourself. Just know what you want from life and who you are.
你将永远与自己在一起。我非常喜欢卡尔·荣格的一句话，那就是：人生的特权是了解真正的自己。而这始于真正能够独处，把一面镜子照向你的灵魂和自我意识并审视它。探索你感到不舒服的部分。尝试新事物。与你的思想共处。和自己约会。只要明白你对生活的要求以及你是谁。
It is the foundation upon which all other. stuff is built. I know how easy it is personally to fill up your social calendar and to never have a Friday or a Saturday off to feel like you're failing if you are, I'll have this intense phomo or to always be dating people. The quiet moments that you end up having when you do that will feel very scary. When in fact when you practice having time alone, you'll realize that it's very fulfilling and that it is the key to living a good life. if you can really hone in on what you actually want from life, what you want from your relationships, and also what you want from yourself, and that's important work that you shouldn't put off that should be your number one priority.
这是构建其他一切的基础。我个人深知，要填满你的社交日程、不放过任何一个周五或周六的晚上是多么容易，如果你做不到就会觉得自己很失败，或者会有强烈的错失恐惧症（FOMO），或者总是在和别人约会。当你这样做时，最终留下的安静时刻会让人感到非常可怕。事实上，当你练习独处时，你会意识到它是非常充实的，它是过上好生活getKey。如果你能真正专注于你对生活、对人际关系、以及对自己的真正诉求，这是你不应该推迟的重要工作，它应该成为你的首要任务。
That's where the list ends. That is our final mistake from this list. I hope that you've taken something away from this. I hope that you've learned from this. There are definitely probably, there were a lot more mistakes that people mentioned. Like, by no means was I able to include every single little thing. that people said was a mistake. Some of them were very specific. But if there is one that you think we haven't touched on that is important that you have learned from through your own life experience,
清单到此结束。这是我们这份清单上的最后一个错误。我希望你从中有所收获。我希望你从中得到了启发。肯定还有很多，人们提到的错误要多得多。我绝不可能把人们说成是错误的每一件小事都涵盖进去。其中一些非常具体。但如果你认为我们没有涉及某个重要错误，而这是你通过自己的人生经验学到的，
leave a comment below. Leave a comment in just below the episode description. What is the biggest mistake you feel like you have made in your 20s? And what do you think people can learn from that? This kind of wisdom is the kind that feels really, really important. And I really loved being able to investigate this and just like, you know, I don't know, kind of like revive my research days. So I hope you enjoyed it. I hope you liked this episode. Share it with a friend who you think may benefit from it as well. Leave a comment, like, subscribe, all those things. Leave a five-star review as well. If you feel cool to do so, it really does help the show grow and expand and reach new people. And make sure you're following me at that psychology podcast as well on Instagram.
请在下方留言。在剧集简介下方留言。你觉得自己20多岁时犯过的最大错误是什么？你认为人们可以从中学到什么？这种智慧感觉非常非常重要。我真的很喜欢能够去调查这一点，就像，你知道的，我不知道，有点像重温我的研究岁月。希望你喜欢。希望你喜欢这一集。把它分享给你认为也可能从中受益的朋友。留言、点赞、订阅，所有这些。如果觉得可以的话，也请留下五星好评，这确实有助于节目成长、扩展并接触到新的人。确保你在Instagram上也关注了“that psychology podcast”。
if you want to contribute to further episodes, a lot of what I learned and what I shared in today's episodes came from DMs and came from people who, you know, follow me on Instagram who were able to contribute. So I hope to see you over there. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself.
如果你想为以后的节目做出贡献，我今天节目中了解和分享的很多内容都来自私信，来自那些关注我的Instagram并能够做出贡献的人。所以我希望能在那儿见到你。但在下一次之前，注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。
And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not saying. to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的很难进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice. and so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
但这并不意味着你必须这么做，请在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次。等等。我伪造过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Manchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app,
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在Iheart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己从另一头走出来。收听《2%》。
That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
这就是IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约好会时，她们开始自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。
Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。